right now i'll ask my question here we
go
uh i had the privilege of
knowing pastor skeed when i was a
student at andrews university and on the
weekends
i just happened to room with the program
director for campus ministries
and it was israel and so he said hey
come on out on the weekends you can help
teach some missionaries and there was a
double-wide mobile home
there outside of ann arbor
two of them
and on sabbath we would eat
rice and and beans i remember that
and
anyways
there was there was a certain
culture of
a statement like higher than the highest
remember that i remember one year the
the mantra was higher than the highest
after the book education higher than the
highest human thought can reach is god's
ideal for his children
and
i think that one of the things that i
drew from
every talk or being around you praise
the lord
is that
there is this
this element of excellence that
that exudes
you mentioned in your talk earlier
that
that christians should be known for
their excellence
and
there's almost this mentality sometimes
that you can be a christian and slovenly
and and late
uh lack of attention to detail uh sloppy
work and so forth uh could you talk a
little bit more about
about being ambitious for the master's
glory
uh
excellence
higher than the highest human thought
can reach and how that can be
incorporated into christian life not for
our own glory but for god's glory
surely um ella white makes a very
interesting comment in the book um
desire of ages page 72 paragraph four
speaking about jesus christ she said
he was not willing to be defective even
in the use of tools
he was as perfect a workman as he was in
character
now pause and think of what she just
said
what she's saying is that when jesus
christ who by training and trade was a
carpenter
when he applied himself to the making of
a chair or a table or whatever he
applied it with the same care with which
he took care of his personal character
which we know to have been sinless and
so she said
he was as perfect a workman
as he was
in character the desire of ages page 72
paragraph four this is an astonishing
statement it is all the more astonishing
when we realize the life of christ in
human form
is an example for us
not most of the life the very life he
lived in
human flesh is an example for you and
him for me but of course we have to
believe that the bible says see is thou
a man
diligent in his business
proverbs 22 29 he shall stand before
kings
he shall not stand before mean men
if you study daniel 6 when darius chose
daniel to be the head of the princes
or the governors he chose him because an
excellent spirit was in him that's what
the bible says and so darius dismissed
the fact that daniel was from another
ethnic group what he saw was the
excellence in daniel
god cannot put a rubber stamp on
sloppiness and mediocrity he cannot do
that and so that's why he said a bit it
was yesterday or whenever it was
excellence is christian behavior because
ultimately
we are representing god
and so when god made the world as i said
genesis 1 31 and god saw everything that
he had made and behold it was very good
many years ago i went to barbados to see
my sister
and she lives in a little house and
there's a little front yard
and someone
mowed the front yard but i i hesitated
to use the word more because there was
no lawnmower
when i saw it i said to her who did this
yard
because the grass was cut around between
rocks that could not be pulled up and i
was just a stone i who
did this that was my first response and
then she told me who it was a brother
from the local church and i said to
myself
the impression it made on me the
thoroughness
with which he did that job
would have drawn me to his church more
than any argument he possibly could have
made of course he's already one of us
and so what i'm saying to you my young
friends and my not so young friends
excellence is required of god's people
as a matter of fact god requires more
excellence from you than he does from
the unbeliever
because you and i have the benefit of
contact with christ
and the unbeliever does not the same way
ours is personal his is more general
because god so loved the world our
connection with christ is personal
consequently we should feel the duty
to be excellent in whatever we do
if we were to do that
we would be the most prized employees in
any work environment
we would be the best students in any
classroom setting
we'd be the best neighbors in any
residential setting
excellence in all that we do
is required of us by god because this is
part of the image of god there is and
was and never will be any mediocrity in
god
and it should not be seen in god's
people now let me say quickly because
this is an academic environment does
that mean you get all a's in your
classes no
it simply means that when you've done
your work you've done the very best you
can do
now that's a b fine but you know in your
you see sabbath keeping is connected to
weekly excellence
you say to yourself or to me what do you
mean
listen to verse 31 of genesis 1. let me
pray father as i speak to your people
girl tell me what to tell them i pray
please in jesus name amen and god saw
everything that he made made
and behold it was very good
then he rested
he rested from a week
of excellent work
when you and i do sloppy work during the
week we know it's been sloppy
then we really can't keep the sabbath
what are you resting from
are you with me you can't rest from
sloppiness you can't rest from that what
are you resting from you you see the
rest must be physical and mental in
other words you must be able to say look
i looked at my week of duties i have
done all i could only god could have
done more
you rest
your conscience isn't bothered you did
not shortcut your employer or your
teacher or your parents i have done all
that i could when the woman anointed the
feet of christ and the disciples rebuked
he said leave her alone she has done
what she could
and all she did was wash her feet
she has done what she could and so all
i'm saying to you is in all that you put
your hand to do and i
make a conscious effort
to do the very best
particularly
in the spiritual area of the life
but if you and i do it in the
educational the social the environmental
it will spill over into the spiritual
the most important of all
we serve a savior
who demonstrated excellence
we must regard excellence
not simply as something we do
but something we are
you